[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hablásemos sobre bután y os pidiera
que me dije seis tres cosas tres cosas
sobre este país sin consultar en google
os atrevéis una es fácil puede que dos
también pero probablemente tres la cosa
se va complicando o me equivoco y no es
raro votar es uno de los países más
desconocidos aislados de todo el mundo
no sólo geográficamente sino también y
sobre todo política y comercialmente te
lo has planteado alguna vez como son las
cosas en este país de que viven quién
manda
bután es un pequeño reino situado en
plena cordillera del himalaya tiene una
extensión muy similar a la de suiza
igual que este último país es también
una nación muy montañosa pero hasta ahí
llegan todas las similitudes con una
población diez veces inferior a la de
suiza y un nivel de desarrollo que la
sitúa entre los países más pobres del
mundo butter es una especie de reino
ermitaño que estuvo completamente
cerrado en sí mismo hasta hace
prácticamente cuatro días su mayor logro
internacional pues según su gobierno ser
el país más feliz del mundo
claro que amigos eso no es algo que
tengamos nada claro en este vídeo nos
adentraremos en bután hablaremos de su
sociedad de su economía y de su sistema
político y no sólo eso también os vamos
a contar algunas cosas que probablemente
nunca subiría imaginado que ocurrirían
en la supuestamente nación más feliz de
la tierra os venís a bután con nosotros
pues arranquemos
[Música]
motivos para ser feliz bután es un país
con un aire tan puro que casi se podría
vender enlatado y es que amigos hablamos
de uno de los países ambientalmente más
intactos y mejor conservados de todo el
planeta para que os hagáis una idea casi
las tres cuartas partes de su superficie
están cubiertas por bosques y el 60% del
territorio nacional está declarado como
zona protegida incluido un parque
natural el santuario de fauna salvaje de
santé que se creó ni más ni menos que
para la preservación del migo o ligeti
el abominable hombre de las nieves y si
en este país se toman la tradición muy
pero que muy en serio
[Música]
en otras palabras bután es algo así como
una reliquia de otra época todo un
paraíso natural en el que el turismo no
estuvo permitido hasta el año 1974 e
incluso hoy si lo quieres visitar
digamos que el turismo aquí es muy
diferente al de cualquier otro lugar del
mundo
[Música]
y es que veréis los turistas que llegan
al país además del transporte tienen que
pagar una tasa diaria que oscila entre
los 200 y los 290 dólares eso sí esta
tasa actúa como una especie de tarifa
plana que incluye guía hotel y comida en
otras palabras la única forma de visitar
este país es reservando un paquete
turístico con el gobierno curioso nos
parece tal vez por todo esto un poco más
de 270.000 son los turistas que visitan
cada año este país
[Música]
en cualquier caso amigos sin duda alguna
el elemento más característico de bután
no tiene nada que ver ni con los
turistas ni con los montañeros ni con
nada por el estilo sino con toda una
innovación política que puso en marcha
su gobierno hace ya casi cinco décadas
en 1972 como una forma de superar las
críticas acerca de los elevados índices
de pobreza del país y al mismo tiempo
tratar de conciliar con el mundo moderno
el particular modelo de vida tradicional
de bután el entonces rey de este país y
missing iwanczuk propuso una nueva forma
de medir el progreso y el bienestar
general pasar del producto interior
bruto y centrarse en el conocido como
índice de felicidad bruta un nuevo
indicador que tiene en cuenta cosas como
el bienestar psicológico las relaciones
con la comunidad la salud del acceso a
la educación o el uso del tiempo eres
decir este nuevo indicador trata de
complementar los aspectos materiales del
progreso con la parte más espiritual y
psicológica del ser humano es al menos
es la teoría
claro qué bueno dicho esto puede que
algunos estéis pensando un interesante
quiere decir entonces que bután es una
especie de potencia de la felicidad pues
no lo cierto es que no tampoco ni
siquiera con este índice del reino del
himalaya se acercan y con mucho a los
primeros puestos
según el reporte de felicidad mundial
del 2019 que prepara anualmente la
iniciativa de naciones unidas- llamada
red de soluciones para el desarrollo
sostenible bután no está en el top 10 ni
en el 20 ni siquiera en el 50 de países
más felices del mundo se sitúa en el
puesto 95 justo por encima de camerún un
puesto que no parece que vaya en
consonancia con la imagen que tiene de
ser uno de los países más felices del
mundo ni con la aparente importancia que
le dan a este concepto
vaya sorpresa por cierto os hago una
pregunta a qué países pensáis que son
los más felices según este curioso
indicador pues amigos el ranking está
liderado por países como finlandia
dinamarca suiza nueva zelanda canadá
israel holanda etcétera etcétera es
decir que al final este particular
ranking de felicidad bruta está muy
relacionado con los índices de
prosperidad libertad económica y riqueza
per cápita en otras palabras al final
cuanto más rico es un país antes o
después también tiende a cosechar
mejores resultados en cuanto a felicidad
sorprendidos no deberíais pero amigos no
nos desviemos como hemos dicho incluso
en este ranking de felicidad bruta bután
se clasifica en un puesto tan bajo como
el 95 vamos que nos lo han colado porque
casi siempre que vemos empresas noticias
relacionadas con este índice siempre
parece que bután es el país más feliz
del mundo y ya veis que no para nada ni
de lejos pero ahora bien porque bután es
en realidad un país tan infeliz
[Aplausos]
pues bien aunque el país haya conseguido
duplicar su esperanza de vida en los
últimos 20 años y escolarizar a casi el
cien por cien de los niños en educación
primaria lo cierto es que las cosas no
van precisamente bien tanto es así que a
día de hoy un cuarto de los casi 800.000
butaneses sobreviven con menos de 1.25
dólares al día que es la cantidad que se
considera como el umbral de pobreza
extrema
de esta forma votan siempre aparece en
la lista de países menos desarrollados
que preparan cada año las naciones
unidas'
y no sólo eso aunque es un país
relativamente tranquilo los crímenes
violentos han aumentado y cada vez son
más frecuentes las bandas callejeras y
el tráfico de bienes básicos y de
alimentos para su venta en el mercado
negro para colmo los cambios climáticos
también están afectando a un país que
simple y llanamente no se había
preparado
el cambio en los patrones climáticos ha
convertido en todo un problema en un
país muy dependiente de la naturaleza un
país donde la industria es prácticamente
inexistente y en el que el 70 por ciento
de la población son granjeros
minifundistas el hecho de que cada vez
nieve menos y que las lluvias que llegan
con mayor irregularidad hace que muchas
cosechas se echen a perder año tras año
amigos la falta de desarrollo técnico de
la agricultura también provoca
situaciones como esta la temperatura se
ha vuelto cada vez más cálida así que
hay más insectos en la fruta y el grano
no lo entiendo pero si continúa así
tendremos muchos problemas para cultivar
comida y alimentos por nosotros mismos
dawa tsering granjero butanés de paro
pero un momento es que acaso es todo
malo en el país del dragón del trueno
pues afortunadamente nos votan también
tiene sus fortalezas por ejemplo durante
los últimos años las cosas han mejorado
la economía ha crecido el gobierno
invierte una buena parte de la tasa a
los turistas en preservar y desarrollar
sus atractivos turísticos y desde luego
hay un campo en el que este país puede
llegar a convertirse en toda una
potencia hablamos de la energía
hidroeléctrica la energía más barata y
de la que bután es ya todo un exportador
gracias a su impresionante geografía
montañosa bután es la meca de la energía
hidroeléctrica de la zona la mayoría de
la potencia producida es exportada a la
india y sólo los ingresos derivados de
estas exportaciones suponen casi el 30
por ciento de los ingresos del gobierno
y el 14 del producto interior bruto la
energía hidroeléctrica es potencialmente
el oro azul de este país
no olvidéis que bután tiene como vecinos
a enormes países que literalmente están
llamados a devorar energía tan solo
entre la india y el cercano a bangladesh
hablamos de más de 1600 millones de
habitantes
[Música]
amigos la mayoría de las centrales han
sido construidas precisamente por
empresas indias y es que la india es de
hecho el mayor aliado de bután tanto en
el terreno político como sobre todo en
el económico a día de hoy la india es el
país del que procede en casi el 90% de
las importaciones y el destino de más
del 80 por ciento de todas las
exportaciones butanesa creo que pocos
países en el mundo tendrán una relación
tan dependiente como la de bután hacia
la india pero por el momento acaso no
falta alguien en toma esta ecuación
seguro que muchos estáis pensando pero
enrique qué demonios pasa con china
de entrada a la ecuación parece perfecta
en la estrategia de expansión del
gigante asiático un país pobre en vías
de desarrollo con una falta
importantísima de inversiones
infraestructuras no se parece el típico
lugar donde a china le gusta invertir y
echar el anzuelo no creéis
lo cierto es que aunque las inversiones
y la ayuda china han crecido en los
últimos años especialmente en lo que
respecta a la salud ya la educación el
reino de bután se mantiene fiel a su
aliado indio tan fiel que incluso ha
llegado a rechazar la oferta de pekín de
formar parte de la nueva ruta de la seda
la gigantesca red de infraestructura
promovida por xi jinping y aunque la
presencia china poco a poco se va
notando por ejemplo una empresa china a
la que construyó la gigantesca estatua
de buda dordain más una estatua cubierta
de pan de oro que se ha convertido en
uno de los símbolos del país la
presencia china sigue siendo residual
pero amigos amigas más allá de sus
peculiaridades sociales o económicas hay
algunas cosas en el supuesto país de la
felicidad de las que nunca se habla
atentos
la cara más desconocida
a ver la imagen que bután transmite al
mundo es la de un país tranquilo
apacible y sobre todo pacífico un
idílico reino budista en pleno himalaya
y en cierta medida puede que lo sea sin
embargo como siempre decimos en visual
político nunca es oro todo lo que reluce
como hemos visto o bután es un país muy
pobre y esa no es su única cara fea que
pensaría y si os contase que bután es en
realidad un país donde ha habido y en
cierto modo sigue habiendo toda una
persecución y discriminación
institucional hacia minorías étnicas
pues eso es ni más ni menos lo que pasa
con los los hampa una minoría indicada y
lengua nepalí fijaos
desde el año 1988 y a lo largo de toda
la década de los 90 decenas y decenas de
miles de personas los hampa fueron
despojadas de su documentación butanesa
y convertidas en apátridas se calcula
que entre 80.000 y 100.000 personas
terminaron desplazadas en campos de
refugiados en nepal y la india campos en
los que estuvieron durante casi dos
décadas antes de poder emigrar a
terceros países en 2017 el departamento
de estado de eeuu en un informe sobre
los derechos humanos en bután apuntó a
que el país todavía tenía presos
políticos de lengua nepalí y que el
gobierno rechazaba a readmitir a muchos
de los refugiados que han reclamado la
ciudadanía butanesa
seguro que estamos hablando de bután del
reino del dragón del trueno del ibérico
país cuyo gobierno supuestamente toma y
mide sus decisiones en términos de
felicidad pues sí y la pregunta es de
dónde viene el odio a esta minoría
étnica pues veréis según el gobierno los
los ampas era un poco menos que unos
recién llegados algo así como
inmigrantes ilegales sin embargo la
realidad es que esta etnia lleva
viviendo en el sur de bután desde el año
1620 y su expulsión no fue en absoluto
algo casual vino dada por las leyes de
ciudadanía butanesa de 1958 y 1985 de
esta manera aunque se les dio la
nacionalidad a muchos los tampa en el
año 58 otros muchos no pudieron
demostrar fehacientemente que residían
en bután antes de ese año una condición
que más tarde en la ley del 85 se exigió
rígidamente y que se aplicó de forma
totalmente arbitraria pensándolo un
momento imaginad que sois una familia de
campesinos que vivís bajo el umbral de
la pobreza vivís prácticamente de lo que
cultiva es probablemente no sepáis ni
leer ni escribir y no existen registros
de propiedad de vuestras tierras ni nada
por el estilo como demonios vais a
demostrar que lleváis viviendo décadas
en ese lugar si el testimonio de
vuestros
no cuenta pues amigos así es como muchos
miembros de esta etnia pasaron de nacer
y vivir en bután a convertirse en
inmigrantes ilegales y ser expulsados
por la fuerza del país algo que
evidentemente tuvo consecuencias
la expulsión forzosa de decenas de miles
de miembros de la etnia los hampa derivó
en todo un conflicto étnico militar que
terminó enfrentando al ejército real de
bután con miembros armados de este grupo
social según el gobierno dos miembros de
las fuerzas de seguridad perdieron la
vida claro que según las fuentes no
oficiales la cifra se eleva a por lo
menos 300 fallecidos y más de 2.000
detenidos
amigos lo cierto es que sistemas
políticos de bután es algo peculiar y no
se parece mucho a una democracia
consolidado
para que os hagáis una idea las primeras
elecciones democráticas fueron ni más ni
menos que en el 2007 y el primer
gobierno elegido completamente por las
urnas en unas elecciones libres no llegó
hasta el 2011 hasta entonces pues simple
y llanamente lo que había era una
monarquía absoluta al más puro estilo
del feudalismo medieval y claro esa
reciente historia de autoritarismo que
es la que explica que todavía en muchos
campos de la política y la sociedad el
respeto por los derechos humanos o las
libertades políticas y sociales de los
ciudadanos pues no sean una prioridad
muchas de las estructuras autoritarias
forjadas por el rey y mi cuarto siguen
aún en pie la monarquía no ha cedido
poder significativo que el sistema
combina mínimas libertades civiles con
el autoritarismo político académico
durbar vital en su libro la democracia
semi autoritaria real de bután en fin
amigos hablamos de un país controlado
férreamente por el gobierno y por la
casa real al que por ejemplo la
televisión no llegó hasta que fue
legalizada en el año 1999 hablamos para
bien o para mal del que tal vez sea uno
de los países con menos influencia de la
globalización en todo el mundo un país
con estructuras medievales al que sin
embargo sus encantos naturales y sobre
todo la invención
el índice de la felicidad bruta lo han
convertido en el imaginario colectivo en
todo un epicentro de la felicidad la paz
y la conservación cultural y ambiental
sin embargo tal y como habéis visto la
realidad como tantas veces ocurre es un
poco diferente a la de los grandes
titulares
[Música]
eso sí aun con todo durante los últimos
años el país ha abrazado un sistema
democrático su economía ha crecido y su
apertura del mundo es a hoy más alta que
nunca antes y desde luego el reino del
dragón del trono es y seguirá siendo uno
de los lugares más enigmáticos y
cautivadores de todo el mundo y la
pregunta es os gustaría ver un vídeo de
visual político desde allí en fin amigos
si este vídeo ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like
suscribiros al canal una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]